you're not going to get any kind of
serious journalism here okay and you're
not going to get it on big tech either
kareem abdul-jabbar you know kareem he
was the basketball star
and then he was an airplane which is my
that's really where i enjoyed his
his work kareem abdul-jabbar
is now saying that big tech should
censor conservatives
and even people who aren't woke just
kind of run-of-the-mill liberals
he says they need to do it because the
conservatives are tweeting
irrational and harmful opinions to
millions
and what's funny his reasoning here is
many americans imbue stars with
political and social intelligence they
just don't have
it doesn't help to be surrounded by
fawning people whose job it is to agree
with everything you say
and you know it's irresponsible and then
they've got to be
censored says kareem abdul-jabbar
a basketball player a very famous
basketball player
and guy who was in some movies and
specifically he was saying that jon
voight should be kicked off
big tech and james woods should as well
two of the only outspoken conservatives
in all of hollywood
those guys are going to come after you
too
it is not conspiracy theory thinking
to say that we need to be skeptical of
these established institutions the
government institutions
and even the institutions outside of the
government
it's the only conspiracy theory is that
those institutions are not political
that that is a truly a crazy conspiracy
theory
there is a i guess you could use the
word conspiracy it's not really a
conspiracy it's just
an establishment it's an established
standard
across all of these different sectors
all of which
are hell-bent on shutting up
conservatives
making sure we don't have a voice you're
not going to get that unity and healing
assuming joe biden gets it january 20th
you are going to get a vindictive
response
revenge and if conservatives don't
prepare for that now
and if we're not prepared to fight on
every front of that not just
the governmental front but also
in commercial life also in educational
life
also in technology if you're not
prepared to fight on all those fronts
we don't stand a chance
[Music]
you